[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir ce nouveau massacre au niger
au moins dix civils ont été tués dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi dans une série
d'attaqués attribuées au groupe
djihadiste nigérian boko haram dans le
sud-est du pays proche du nigeria nous
serons à niamey dans ce journal nous
irons également en tunisie vous verrez
que les femmes originaires d'afrique sub
saharienne arrivés dans le pays ont
parfois du mal à se faire une place même
si les mauvais traitements et le racisme
n'empêche pas certaines de réussir et à
la fin de ce journal nous vous
emmènerons à la rencontre d'une
dénicheuse de talents nigériane son
agence refaire les futurs top model qui
défileront sur les podiums pour quatre
coins du monde reportage à suivre à la
fin de cette édition
le niger de nouveau frappée par les
attaques terroristes
cette fois c'est le sud est du pays qui
en a fait été la cible cette zone proche
du nigeria a été frappé par une série
d'attaqués au moins dix civils ont été
tués un massacre attribué aux groupes
djihadistes boko haram on part tout de
suite à niamey retrouver notre
correspondant à un rôle si rare harold
pour l'instant pas de déclaration
officielle que sait-on exactement sur
les circonstances de cette série d'attac
effectivement meriem pour l'instant pas
de bilan officiel
et pas de communiqué des autorités ce
que l'on sait à ce stade c'est que les
hommes armés plausiblement affiliés à
boko haram sont venus du nigeria voisin
ap ils ont attaqué le le village la
commune de gué ski-roues trois villages
ont été touchés par ces attaques et au
moins dix civils tués vous l'avez dit
mais on parle d'un bilan qui pourrait
s'alourdir car on l'a appris ce matin de
source sécuritaire et bien dans ces
villages il ya des femmes qui manquent à
l'appel il y a des possibilités des
probabilités qu'il y ait eu des
enlèvements de femmes durant ses
attaquants harold ces attaques
interviennent dans une période de
relative accalmie
oui une période d'accalmie qui touche
déjà peut-être malheureusement à sa fin
cette région un du niger le sud est du
niger tout proche d'une région
d'intenses combats d'un temps ce conflit
au nord du nigeria est assez tributaire
en fait de tout ce qui se passe dans le
nord du nigeria à la fin février on s'en
souvient pendant la conférence des
cadres le président de la république du
niger mohamed bazoum avait salué une
nouvelle période d'accalmie un relatif
cessez le feu dans le sud est du niger
mais on voit que ces espoirs ont été un
peu déçus mais il avait aussi promis à
cette époque-là d'amener de recruter 500
soldats dans former 500 autres des
forces qui sont très attendus par les
par les villageois de la région
maintenant
d'autant plus maintenant en fait merci
beaucoup à redire notre correspondant à
niamey merci pour ces précisions au
cameroun l'enseignant devenue le symbole
de la grève du secondaire qui paralyse
le système éducatif depuis près de trois
semaines est décédé à l'âge de 49 ans
hamidou avait ému l'opinion publique
après une dizaine d'années de travail
sans matricule et sans salaire il venait
d'être intégré dans la fonction publique
la correspondance à yaoundé de marcel
amont coup c'est à travers une photo et
une pancarte où il était écrit 2012 2022
sans matricule 10 ans sans salaire
publié sur sa page facebook que les
camerounais ont découvert cet homme
frêle au visage émacié qui disait
travailler sans salaire depuis 2012
devenue virale sur les réseaux sociaux
cette publication en a rapidement fait
le sait molle et le visage du mal-être
les enseignants cameroun est en grève
depuis près de trois semaines à travers
le collectif au ts entendez on a trop
supporter pour revendiquer de meilleures
conditions de travail face à l'émotion
suscitée par cette publication le
gouvernement avait annoncé l'intégration
en urgence de hamidou au sein de la
fonction publique camerounaise mais
malheureusement le sort va s'acharner
sur cet homme de 49 ans dont on a appris
le décès ce mardi 8 mars des suites de
maladies pour rendre hommage à celui
qu'il considérait comme un martyr de la
craie les enseignants en grève en
décrété ce 9 mars mercredi noir et ont
annoncé la poursuite de l'opération créé
morte jusqu'à ce que toutes leurs
l'indication soient satisfaites
n'en reste de l'actualité en bref et en
images le président sénégalais macky
sall également président en exercice de
l'union africaine s'est entretenu ce
mercredi avec son homologue russe
vladimir poutine au nom de l'ua macky
sall à je cite solliciter un cessez le
feu durable en ukraine le président
sénégalais a salué son écoute
l'ukraine a annoncé son intention de
rapatrier ses casques bleus déployés en
république démocratique du congo qui en
a informé l'onu ce mercredi au sein de
la monusco sur un total d'environ à
quinze mille militaires le contingent et
craignent un compte 250 soldats
principalement dans l'aviation le fils
du président ougandais yoweri musevini
le général
musica une roue gaba commandant de
l'armée de terre a annoncé mardi sa
retraite militaire à l'âge de 47 ans une
annonce qui suscite des spéculations sur
une possible ambition présidentielle aux
élections de 2026
on part à présent en tunisie pour
s'intéresser à la condition de la femme
subsaharienne elles sont nombreuses à
avoir migré dans ce pays où les droits
de la femme sont les plus avancés dans
le monde arabe mais ces avancées ne les
aide pas forcément même si certaines
certains dans certaines d'entre elles
pardon s'accroche et parviennent à
réaliser leurs projets reportage de
lille i à blaise et âme dit lee
au restaurant la marmite sénégalaise le
service du midi est le plus chargé pour
nogaye qui sert des étudiants
subsahariens mais aussi des clients
tunisiens dans un quartier du centre
ville de tunis
oui et tu vois la marmite est presque
déjà fini quand tu arrives même à 13
heures le chemin n'a pas été facile pour
cette entrepreneuse venu en 2013 en
tunisie pour travailler comme aide
ménagère dans une maison elle n'a réussi
à ouvrir son restaurant que trois ans
plus tard
il me dit que vous n'avez pas le droit
de faire du
doigt la réussite de nos gars y reste
une exception en tunisie beaucoup de
migrants sub saharienne doivent
travailler au noir et ont peu de droit
myriam a accepté de nous raconter son
histoire en gardant l'anonymat par
exemple tu travaille chez quelqu'un et
c'est la personne te dit tu as volé
quelque chose tu as volé un bijou
j'appelle la police chaque fois que la
police vient ça va être une demande de
carte de séjour de contrat de travail
alors qu'on n'a jamais de contrat de
travail quand elle parvient à trouver un
travail dans un centre d'esthétique elle
est confrontée au racisme de son
employeur elle nous insulter chaque fois
elle nous disait que nous sommes des
noirs que l'on sent mauvais myriam a
participé avec l'onu un collectif de
dessinateurs tunisiens à l'écriture
d'une bande dessinée pour sensibiliser
sur son expérience mais selon perles
étudiante centrafricaine est membre
d'une association il faut aussi se
mobiliser pour mieux dénoncer comme avec
des formations sur la traite humaine en
dans les formations at elle croque parce
que la plupart le temps elles sont
exploitées parce qu'elles ne sont pa r
forclaz en 2018 la tunisie a été l'un
des premiers pays dans le monde arabe a
voté une loi contre le racisme et les
discriminations
mais jusqu'à présent peu de femmes
subsaharienne arrive à faire valoir
leurs droits
direction le liberia où la délinquance
juvénile prend de l'ampleur après 14 ans
de guerre civile marquée par
l'enrôlement des enfants soldats le pays
a bien du mal à aider sa jeunesse des
jeunes souvent désoeuvrés et livrés à
eux mêmes reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux à l'inter gianni et samuel
bernard
la cour de l'école d'une banlieue de
monrovia à la mi-journée un lieu
désormais marqué par un drame c'est ici
qu'un mouvement de foule en plein
rassemblement chrétien entraîne la mort
de 31 personnes pro se souvient du
moment où des jeunes hommes armés de
couteaux arrive et attaque les fidèles
trou les gens sont sans voix par ici
et pendant ce temps des individus sauté
par dessus le mur pour après a dressé
les gens à leur argent
six personnes sont arrêtées par la
police cinq d'entre elles sont toujours
en détention ce chef communautaire a
perdu sa fille de 15 ans dans la
bousculade
il regrette le désoeuvrement de la
jeunesse libérienne
le soir ils détournent les motos taxis
et leur vole leur argent la jeunesse est
perdue qui sera à la tête de notre pays
demain quant aux enfants gâchent leur
vie dans le ghetto
aujourd'hui pointé du doigt ces jeunes
appelés zogo sont perçus comme une
conséquence en direct de la guerre
civile de 1989 à 2003 des milices
rebelles recrute de force des milliers
d'enfants
aujourd'hui cette réputation
d'ex-combattants leur colle toujours à
la peau mais leur première préoccupation
reste la pauvreté et l'addition
stupéfiants
on reste juste entre nous on dit que les
gens qui fument de la drogue mais sont
bien dans leur tête mais pour nous c'est
à cause des frustrations de nos familles
qui ruine le vide nous voulons que le
gouvernement construit un centre de
désintoxication pour que nous puissions
sortir du ghetto
pour les forces de l'ordre la seule
répression ne suffit pas à traiter les
nombreux problèmes de ces jeunes
ce n'est pas seulement le problème de la
police c'est un problème national et
toutes les parties prenantes doivent se
réunir pour voir comment pour remédier à
ce problème des jeunes défavorisés
face au manque de financement et de
centres de désintoxication
difficile de briser le cycle de la
toxicomanie et de la violence
et ce soir on vous parle d'une chasseuse
de tête elle s'appelle elisabeth is your
aux ailes et cette pionnière de la mode
nigériane dirige une agence à des gosses
devenu une référence pour les plus
grands directeurs artistiques mondiaux
elle organisait récemment fioutch faith
africa un casting de trois mois dans
sept pays africains objectif repérer les
futurs doc modèle notre correspondant au
nigeria moïse gomis a suivi pour nous ce
concours reportage
au bord de cette piscine d'un hôtel de
luxe de négoce ses mannequins débutants
sont concentrés lors de cette répétition
le balancement des bras le regard au
loin le plus de droits
chaque détail compte pour john a faim
depuis cinq ans il est l'un des
recruteurs de l'agencé bête model
management
les marques ne veulent pas seulement
qu'un mannequin porte leurs vêtements
mais qu'ils ressentent leurs objectifs
leur passion c'est là que la
personnalité entre en jeu vous devez
être quelqu'un qui lorsque vous entrez
dans une pièce ne soit pas timide vous
devez avoir du charisme
dépensant de cette agence élisabeth hiss
yoro sept anciennes miss nigeria
grande-bretagne gère aujourd'hui près de
300 mannequin en afrique cette
délicieuse de talent a gagné la
confiance de grandes maisons de haute
couture en s'inspirant de son court
parcours dans la mode elle guide et
forme ses recrues à 17 ans je voulais
vraiment être mannequin mais quelques
années plus tard ça n'a pas marché pour
moi et j'ai décidé de créer ma propre
agence de mannequin à l'âge de 24 ans je
sais à quel point les mannequins veulent
être repérés et connut donc recruté pour
moi c'est une aventure une permanente où
je suis heureuse quand je les découvre à
l'âge de 15 ou 16 ans en lançant le
concours futur fès africa élisabeth hiss
yoro ne recrute plus en priorité au
nigeria 1600 candidats auditionnés dans
sept pays du continent et via internet
puis vins sélectionnés pour un camp
d'entraînement intense avant une finale
à l'ego devant un parterre de stars
nigériane ses mannequins font leurs
premiers pas certains d'entre eux ont
déjà signé avec boeuf modèle ce
management un contrat désormais reconnu
comme un label de qualité par les
agences occidentales de mannequinat la
prochaine étape pour nous et de leur
obtenir des signatures dans des agences
internationales
je suis tellement contente pour les deux
finalistes c'est un spectacle incroyable
en remportant cette première édition
l'angolaise ana campos et le rwandais
kenza ont débuté leur carrière dans une
grande agence internationale et tenter
de suivre les pas de maillot à nicholas
et davidson aux bénévoles de mannequins
très demandés et lancer tous les deux
paris les abolitions
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
largo winch
[Musique]